the mushrooms Sikhs and our opinions
rests upon what it tells eloquently of
itself in a pool not to the mind I am
older than the thought in your species
which is his setup fifty times older
than the oral history though I have been
on earth for ages I am from the stars
my home is Noah Wyle unplanned former
many worlds scattered through the
shining disc of the galaxy have been the
descendants which allow a source an
opportunity for life the month you see
is the part of my body - given the two
sexes riyals and the son of a my true
body is just a fine a network of the
progress rolling through the soil these
networks may may cover acres and the may
have far more connections than the
number and if human the brain my work is
nearly immoral only this identification
of a planet or the slow eminent parents
are and the more like me and not by
knees and impossible it was swaying
because it's a certain misconceptions in
your mama on the reality all networks in
the galaxy are really hyper tightly
communication across space and time the
mighty body is as a travel as a spider's
web but like the collectivity pipe
reminded memory is as a vast historical
archive over the career of the evolving
and intelligence on many worlds in our
spiral stars or space you see
is as a vast ocean to those heart rate
forms that they have the ability to be
reduced from a source for source or our
harvest organic set up to the snow
across the EOS is autonomous state rated
minutes or anything like forms any
suspended animation from a minute Ennis
of the years in Development Act is made
with a suitable environment few species
are minded only myself and I basically
all nearly relatives have achieved the
communication mode and a memory capacity
that the main accessible leading members
of community of galactic intelligence
power communication mode operates is as
a sea critter that will not be of any
liability to me penalty but the means
videography it is the occurrence of
psilocybin and insulin that addict
pathways of the mining party that open
this for me and in my cinema lots of
issues greetings to many worlds you as
an individual and a mankind as a species
are the brink of the performer
management of a symbiotic relationship
with the mind and the material that will
eventually carry massey and earth in the
middle acted mainstream of our students
an affinity for you to recognize other
the rise of the metabolism of you your
most advanced series as a politics and
the society have been abandoned only as
far as than the notion of collectivism
but buddy on the cohesion of the members
as a species and it was singing
historical origins of them there are
richer and even more baroque evolution
possibilities cinema this is one of
these semi do that this is a relation
and a mutual dependence and then holiday
event interface for both of the species
in the fall cinema art relationships
between myself and the civilized forces
of fire animals have been established
many times and in many places throughout
the long ages of my development these
relationships have been immediately
useful within my means the knowledge hi
can I Drive Shiv Sena come out to
believe that I will train this knowledge
for a freely ticket to New Worlds around
Suns let's say I can and then a near
galaxy senator to secure remain
eternally existent as down along river
crossing the time I am offering this is
a green limit of higher beings and there
are areas we got to get out of say over
the ball on the way ahead
am I seeing that Network has no organ is
to move the world no hands
but higher animals with the mobility of
abilities can be become partners with a
star knowledge within me and if they act
in a good faith we be her below
themselves and they're from a pair of
teacher to the middle in worlds all
citizens of our us to start our swarm or
air or to